[Musique]
ils sont fiers les vautours d'être l'une
des plus anciennes familles françaises
du cirque déjà sous napoléon iii
l'arrière arrière grand mère de tarass
boulba était danseuse de corps d un jour
à chartres elle se fit remarquer par
l'empereur qui s'exclame ah oh quel beau
tour ainsi était né la dynastie des
beaux tours
aujourd'hui les frères vautours ils sont
quatre se produisent dans les cirques du
monde entier fred présente des panthères
paul des chiens
lucien des chimpanzés et puis bien sûr
emilien beau tour sous le chapiteau de
jean richard présente les tig ou si vous
préférez tarass boulba
aujourd'hui ce sont les tigres mais je
crois que vous avez aussi dressé des
lions il n'y a pas très longtemps
bah j'ai présenté tout je suis parti en
espagne 55 avec un numéro mix tigres et
lions
j'avais quatre tickets quatre pions et
après eux la suite j'ai dressé plusieurs
nino
[Musique]
alors pourquoi vous avez choisi le nom
de tarass boulba à satiété d'autres
choses à mal à voir un film avec hugh
bruller et la personnalité de yul
brynner mam a ébloui énormément
[Musique]
pour les partout c'était lentilles
moment ça va avec mentionnant un micro
de la colle suis dans l'équipe aurait
voulu parce que la matinée sa famille
aurait
faisait défaut
c'est pas tout à fait mais on allonge
les cils pour les civils entre filles
jora tant pis les enfants sont les
premiers cépages politique c'est sur sa
radio
voilà je suis arrivé d'italie
j'ai eu le plaisir de rencontrer mon
frère que lui doit aussi dresseur de
chimpanzés nous sommes quatre frères et
nous sommes tous dans les animals mon
frère il s'est il fait les tigres et
nous enseigne d'ikea faire les
chimpanzés quoi alors évidemment ce
n'est pas la même chose
tarass boulba ne peut pas vivre avec ses
tigres mais vous je vois que vous vivez
en famille un traitement parce que ce
sont des bêtes qu'il faut beaucoup
d'affection et pour le dressage
naturellement si ce sont des bêtes qu'on
ne peut pas avoir par la force puisque
ce sont des bêtes que si vraiment on les
bouscule tout de suite ils se rendent
nerveuses ils veulent plus rien faire
alors bella dans ses bras gina jean haas
est la fille d'un grand chef patrick et
à 17 ans vous en avez combien j'en ai
huit camions comment arrive-t-on alors
ça faire des tours bien voyez-vous des
fois ils font une chose qui est très
astucieuse et alors on essaye de la
continuer
est-ce qu'ils ont des dons pour un
exercice plus particulièrement que qu'un
autre nous supposons que tout ce qu'un
artiste peut faire peuvent vous êtes
sévère
il faut pas être sévère qu'en qui savent
rien faire
foi de sévères quand ils savent le faire
et qui ne veulent pas le faire parce que
allah ce moment là c'est vraiment c'est
vraiment parce que ils en sont
capricieux ou comment on commence la
journée à quelle heure eh ben je pars
chelsea repart à 3h 3h30 du matin
je suis le cirque je pars à 3h03 andy je
suis né au cirque en somme vous êtes
seul artiste à vous lever aussitôt je
suis le seul artiste parce que j'ai les
animaux le comprendre les animaux compte
avant tout
plus vite arriver plus vite les animaux
sont soignés
c'est le bifteck pour midi pour vous et
votre famille c'est plus fun pour mes
pensionnaires
exactement c'est votre famille en fin de
course enfin c'est ma famille qui se
compose de huit ligues sibérienne alors
là vous êtes en train de préparer le
repas de midi vous avez sorti la viande
du frigo du camion frigo oui nous avons
sorti la viande du camion frigo qui nous
rend sur la viande tous les quinze jours
environ
mais tous les dompteurs prépare la
viande comme ça pour leurs bêtes nom du
dr no et moi et j'ai toute façon j'ai
toujours préparé ma viande j'ai toujours
aimé préparer la viande mais qu'il
possède en tout 35 un homme deux années
je suis docteur entre cinq années que je
prépare la donne pour meetic
c'est plusieurs jamais une autre qui m'a
préparé la gueule
[Musique]
quelles sont d'après vous les
principales qualités nécessaires pour
pouvoir présenter des tigres le
caractère caractère c'est à dire voilà
force au-dessus d'études physique
[Musique]
au bluff et les animals faut faire voir
qu'on est plus fort que google et je
donne moi aller
or
[Musique]
yahoo
alors justement j'ai remarqué vous
gueulez beaucoup parce que c'est comme
ça qu'ils comptaient et moi sommes
plusieurs docteurs chacun sa façon de
présenter cette balle dans la cage
vous savez bien sûr mais jamais ce fou
et ateliers les bêtes
et oui parce que les bêtes je les touche
pas vraiment c'est la voix qui les fait
qui les fait travailler la voix fortes
n'ont qu'eux ont fait voir qu'on est
plus fort que l'autre on parlait très
fort avec les animaux et je vous
remarqué une chose ça fait beaucoup
d'années que je travaille des animaux
j'ai jamais eu des coups de pattes
vraiment fort et j'ai été fort avec les
animaux j'ai poussé ce cas là un coup de
pelle s'en fout et ça réagit travail et
généré pendant de longues années sans
fouet sa cravache charia dans les mains
et faire démarrer avec mon point à la
volonté j'allais sur eux ont fait des
gestes et là l'image que je devais
partir en face
pourquoi parce que j'étais blocher sur
eux il démarre et rien dans les mains je
me mettant à sauter et le tea party ils
à leur place je t'appelais moussa a
c'est la volonté c'est là c'est la force
peut encore penser que si un dresseur a
peur des animaux les animaux le centre
moi je pense qu'il faut pas avoir peur
faut faire face à lima si l'animal n'est
sûr vous vous devez aller à la rencontre
de lui et que les plus forts que lui me
action voilà ils font quoi c'est comme
un chien le regard c'est important est
ce que c'est important est ce que les
tigres vous regarde
j'avais acquis qui me charger d'un
regard je le faisais coucher devant moi
ça rien dans les mains le regard mâcher
coller dessus et se bloquer
et quant à lui chargé de veille du
parquet du tap aurez jusqu'au fond de la
cage
darras boulba est ce que il vous arrive
d'avoir peur de temps en temps quand
même
non pardon ça je peux pas dire gg
moi j'ai jamais eu peur des bêtes jamais
mais jamais arrivé vous avez eu des
accrochages
j'ai eu des accrochages mais pas grave
faut pas avoir pouvoir exercer votre
femme un peu la femme dont ma femme
surveille
vous savez que j'ai huit tigres et je
peux pas avoir les yeux partout avec ans
jeudi elle a peur à la peur bon ben je
ne sais je ne sais pas exactement là bas
aussi
je pense que c'est non parce que moi
exactement quand je suis la cage
je ne vois pas ce que les bêtes peuvent
faire derrière moi ou alors d'un côté
vous savez une principale connue dans la
cage
c'est d'avoir s'aperçoit le sureau
tunnel voilà ce que si vous arrive
quelque chose vous passiez et médias
nous allons faire partir les clients
vous restez il ya moins de danger
je vous ai pris par un tigre vous savez
les huit dans la cage aux attitudes
déchets t il nos projets vraiment chaud
la principale je pense c'est d'avoir
quelqu'un sur à la porte du tunnel vous
avez été blessé
oui mais c'est un cas quelqu'un peter k
pas été baissée dans la carrière tout le
monde les docteurs étaient enfin pas
blesser le grave grave le plus grave que
j'ai eu c'est resté sans pantalon dans
la cage
c'est arrivé ça rien le pantalon était
resté à la patte du tigre ça c'est
arrivé
[Musique]
et quand il arrive qu'un tigre prend
froid cela arrive
ou est-ce arrivé qu'est ce qui se passe
à temps la grippe qu'il est malade sa
c'est des problèmes souvent fasse venir
le vétérinaire est encore m énerve que
ce soit bon endormi le tig pour faire
des piqûres faut c'est difficile à
soigner un animal enfin je crois que
vous suivez ça de très près évidemment
moi quand ils ne mangent pas pendant un
deux trois jours alors je commence à
m'inquiéter énorme m j'appelle avait
traîné à charge de vétérinaires le mieux
à peu près je connais un petit peu aussi
ce que ce qui l'a alors j'explique aux
vétérinaires et lui le soir sur la base
ce que je lui dis non
[Musique]
enfin c'est une ville que vous avez bien
c'est ma vie j'ai toujours fait de ma
vie je suis né dans une caravane
je suis né dans une voiture et je peux
pas changer 50 ans pour changer maman ça
sera difficile
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]